you were a guy who started up in
stand-up comedy like everyone else you
weren't you know in fact you were a shoe
salesman very true and as a shoe
salesman the people that you worked with
said hey you know your funny guy you
should go and try stand-up comedy but
but but Kevin it seems to me in your
past like up until the point you were a
shoe salesman you didn't have fantasies
of being a comedian you didn't sit there
in fantasize on one day I'll grow up and
be a comedian I wanted to be an
entertainer right I didn't know that
being a comedian was gonna take me to
these levels I didn't know how to go
about being a comedian right I think I
was saying I was a fan of Eddie Murphy
and Pryor and in rock and Chappelle but
I didn't know how to do what they did
somebody pointed me in the direction and
when I went in that direction and I got
on the stage I said yeah I don't want to
I don't do anything else this is it when
you were growing up in Philadelphia you
I mean you talk about a shitty childhood
I mean you had a really shitty childhood
but do you ever sit there and look at
your childhood and say well that led me
to being a comedian because because you
got tons of material out of it I
wouldn't change it I wouldn't change it
one bit your mom seems like a really
bright woman she worked at the
University of Pennsylvania right the
reason why I'm the way I am is cuz my
mom was strong know that did it may have
affected my mom but my mom was such a
strong woman that she said look
regardless of what your father's doing
and where he is I have a job doing
raising you you're gonna do what you're
supposed to doing you're gonna grow up
to be two intelligent men right me and
my brother school was of the importance
and then I neighborhood it wasn't a good
neighborhood she kept us off the streets
I applaud my mother why'd she keep you
off the street how did you not fall in
I'm a strict man yeah lights on you in
the house would she whack you in the
head if you know when you're in the gym
you don't get dressed my ass you lost
your mom to cancer yes that had to be
painful now that that was tough on me
yeah that's where I went through
something just because of how close me
and my mother were isn't it nice though
that she got to see your great success
she didn't get to see it at its highest
level but now I look at it as my angel
so I know that I have somebody watching
over me that literally sees what's going
on I have a force field around me are
you religious I'm I'm religious to the
point I believe in God right in church
every Sunday I'm
not giving people scriptures every time
I shake their hand I'm not that guy so
look so you decide you go to college
mm-hmm you go for two years to Temple
University then you get out of here okay
don't even call it Temple University I
went to Temple right and and basically I
didn't have the right credentials to
stay at symbol so I went to Community
College here in New York two years it
was for two weeks two weeks yeah there
you go
not the best theory yeah not the best
student are you a disappointment to your
mother at that point because she's so
smart
my mother was a professor at the
University of Penn like you said so I
could have went to the University to
Penn for free so when you start going to
be a shoe salesman stuff is she
disappointed in you she gave me a year
she said go you got one year to figure
it out if you do not figure it out you
have to do it my way and she helped you
out financially this days she supported
me and she would hide your money she
would give you money but she'd hide it
in the Bible to make sure you were
reading the Bible right here a true
story and I was late on my rent I was
late on my rent for about two months
right and she kept asking me that I read
the Bible and I was getting pissed off
as a mom stop with the religion okay
like I'm gonna get I'm gonna get evicted
right I need you to get me the money
she's like let me know when you read
your Bible then we could talk about the
money she said it for the longest
finally one day this is a true story
hand one day I'm in the room and I'm
like your mom is really tripping like yo
they're gonna evict me right but let me
just let me just open this Bible and
read the scripture I'm gonna pray I'm
gonna pray about this I opened up the
Bible and literally like seven months of
rent unbelievable and I'm sitting there
and in fact she's so smart because she
knew where to put it and after that I
said you know what I gotta do my mom
this service and I started reading a
scripture every day and you still do
that no and you know growing up while
your mother was your mother had to put
up with a lot of [ __ ] not only your
father you had some crazy [ __ ]
relatives right I mean but what was it
yet you still do you had a uncle that
was in jail or something all the way to
doing it and then Richard jr. gets out
of jail and he still thinks he has not
put prison out of his mindset yeah very
true thing you say when you talk to your
uncle there's another disconnect because
he thinks
imprison or talk sex and you don't know
what the [ __ ] he's talking about my
uncle Richard jr. came here right now
anything you passed him he would say
you'd put it on the table slide because
that's what you do in prison yeah I
guess I'm not going so I don't know
pretty that a big effect that he eats
the way he eats is like you know hey man
it's all right nobody's coming he's puts
the plate he bit down the shoving it
real thing you're right he's slow